now it's time that we have
the academy panel discussion on future
of bioinformatics and data science in
india challenges and opportunities
as i had introduced dr unsure and dr
suchi i would now like to take this time
out to introduce dr sagan
dr sagar is working in the area of
computational biology
from last 15 years he has served as
various academic and administrative
positions in academic institutions he
has published 30 plus research articles
in peer reviewed national and
international journals and
has one patent as well he has received
foreign grant from bst served to conduct
research on asthma and allergic diseases
he is a life member of resigners and
related disorder society of india and
bioclue society of india as well he has
delivered 10 invited talks in national
and international conferences and
seminars we are pleased to have you all
among us and
uh dr mohammed i would now like to pass
on the stage to you to take this session
thank you sunalika and it's uh it's an
honor to be here on this academic panel
as a moderator with all the educators
here amongst us
so um one of the main objective coming
to this session and learning about the
different application of bioinformatics
and leading to the fact that uh the very
important fact is about the
interdisciplinary nature of this uh
subject bioinformatics and with this
substantial growth and growing influence
of bioinformatics in health and
environment and the society how we can
utilize this uh how we can integrate
this into our education how well we can
integrate this what are the challenges
and where where are we with all of this
uh
in india and specifically what are the
new
uh
opportunities that we see in india in
terms of uh the new educational policy
and then the challenges and the
benefits of bioinformatics being a
subject or the research behind the
bioinformatics could be
something that could be done online and
like as uh dr anju said that many of her
projects are are between labs and it's
collaborative in nature so how different
it is from you know traditional research
versus bioinformatics and the
collaborative nature of all of this and
then uh the the some of some of the
promising areas because we have a huge
community of students who are biologists
who are coming from a background of
biotechnology and other life science uh
backgrounds where the
they would help with the promising areas
that an expert is seeing in india and
asia where there are opportunities which
would bring us to the last point would
be the job opportunities in india and
academia and uh like for students from
different backgrounds who are competing
masters some of them starting at a high
school level versus someone who is doing
masters in phd in bioinformatics and
starting from there so these are some of
the questions that our team thought
would be helpful for the students based
on their feedback as well as uh based on
what we have been observing as a
bioinformatics edu training and
educational company working with some of
these students who are joining us and
working with the expert and developing
some of the
some of the
projects while
learning a lot of skill sets so with
that introduction um i would want to
invite all the panelists to have this
academic to be a part of this academic
panel discussion to help uh find answers
or to have that discussion to give their
opinion and with that like let's uh we
would want to start with this
question of
is there a need for data science
education for life science students now
to define this uh question uh because
bioinformatics we as we know and as from
our experience has been evolving really
rapidly and that's what we have observed
in the presentations as well that uh i
mean the the integration of new research
there are thousands of articles getting
published there are new algorithms which
are coming up and there are new uh new
data types that we are now uh
um that we are not now looking at and
during dr anshu's presentation we saw
that there are new updates which are
really important now uh to cover so like
how can we do this effectively and is
there a need for like education and
revision of those curriculums so
uh maybe we can start with uh
dr sagar who's joining and he's a
seasoned uh
um educator so uh
welcome sir and uh what are your
thoughts on bioinformatics and data
science education in india and uh
especially your experience in amity
university mumbai
uh thank you so much for a nice
introduction
as i am audible properly
yes yes
so as we see that uh
data science requirement in the life
sciences and actually it is a must
if we see that in the biotechnology and
other courses are there
uh now the experimental things that is
equipment things are tremendously
developed that is if you know
that is earlier won't detail before
their peoples are doing everything in
the labs with the help of
doing essays and so on
at that time the limited data is there
limited outcome is there if suppose
someone doing an experiment on a protein
it's just going to uh purify the protein
and then they're just doing a acid along
with that if someone uh
doing a work of genomics in that case
also they just went to amplify and deal
with only uh single
gene molecules but now there are the
tremendous advancement is there i think
uh in this techniques for example
protein purification is there
genuine sequences in there so
uh
there is a large amount of the data is
generated if you see that
if single run of iron torrent machine
they just give you uh 300 gb of the data
and
then it is very much important to
analyze this data how you just process
this data and analyze this data now the
efforts of experimental biologists is uh
reduced in some extent but they need to
learn this data science
advanced data science because the data
which is generated by these techniques
that is there our mass spec is there so
what data output is there that is huge
data is there and you need to process
the data and you have to come up with
some useful information out of it for
example if uh
you run the
mass spec then also you will get a large
amount of the masses you have to analyze
which are the important molecules or
which are the protein expressed by a
particular cell mostly uh we talking
about the
cancerous cell and healthy cell so
suppose you
perform the mass spec analysis
then
uh to
identify these masses and proteins
uh you need to uh learn this advanced
data science then and then only you just
able to handle uh so for that you need
to learn the
perl
requirement is there python requirement
is there our requirement is that so
these languages will be helpful to you
to process the data and associated tool
which is able to analyze what components
are there and then you just come up with
a
particular protein or particular gene
which is expressed or expressed in that
diseased cell and
which is not there in the healthy cell
so uh if you see there is a perception
in india that is the bioinformatics
peoples are
looking at bioinformatics that is they
just only
uh give some artistic images and for
publication only means peoples are only
in that area that is only blocking
simulation and we just creating a
picture for publication itself means if
you uh see the approaches of the
experimental biologist they just
want only you just to do the talking and
give it to us then we will add it and we
will publish the data but
these things are now changed that is all
companies have developed a lot of
pipelines are there and even the normal
biologists able to do this talking and
simulation stuff now the need of the
data science that is people need or
student need to learn advanced languages
as well as advanced tools to process and
analyze the data generated by this uh
genomics and proteomics uh machines
which
currently people are using
thank you thank you so much for your
insights on that so to summarize it i
think uh you're saying that and also
like that could be seen is that the wet
lab technology has evolved and the data
generation is now easy now compared to
before when we were focused more on
single experiments generating now we are
discussing and we are generating high
throughput data which is uh simpler to
generate than before and also less cost
effective i think and the
the
requirement is now more for the analysis
part because the data generation
capabilities have increased the
technology has evolved
so that that's how data science is now
becoming a very important tool to handle
this
data to get meaningful insights from it
uh that requires coding uh some of the
coding
challenges then someone has to be
maybe
learn more about how to apply maybe than
a hardcore coding but to be able to
apply that basic coding is of course is
needed and some bioinformatics related
coding information would be needed for
the students to dive into this field
which is getting now uh maybe
the
way to access this is becoming easier um
with the
come with the companies bringing this
pipelines and also
labs such as dr ranchos
are generating those resources to be
utilized by the students
yes
okay that's uh that's something very
insightful i think uh maybe now uh we
learned about that that why data science
is important from a bio bioinformatics
prospective and how also bioinformatics
has been seen before by the by
biologists where they can see very few
applications and as the data has grown i
guess uh so tremendously now we are
getting all those insights and that
awareness is somehow coming into picture
so um the the question the next question
that i would want to ask
dr anshu is that how how do you tackle
these challenges
or integration of this information into
students
curriculum and the courses like are are
the university adopting to these new
new technologies and approaches and
integrating them all there are other
opportunities that the students are
getting to learn about this uh through
some maybe internships or something like
that so is there a structure or is there
a is there a way that the universities
are kind of incorporating this into
their into their
core structure
right
so so
in the new education policy as you know
the way the core structure is to me for
undergrads is that after first year they
wish to move fields they should be able
to do that
so
recently i have designed a course for
the new education policy for undergrad
and data analysis
for madhya pradesh so i'm on the board
of studies to basically design that
course so the problem is not designing
the course but i have also told them
parallely is that who is going to teach
it
you we don't have enough people here in
the country who can really take up these
courses with the students the course
design is not the challenge here we can
write anything on paper
but the ultimate challenge is to put
that to practice
now national laboratories are not
equipped to handle the size of students
that we currently generate in university
systems we cannot do that despite the
fact we try our best we can handle
probably a few thousands but we are not
talking about numbers and thousands here
so and we need that kind of a workforce
to really understand it
so then it everything boils down to the
fact that how motivated these students
are
to learn these skills
so i think the job that the universities
can do here
even if they cannot teach the students
the hard skills
if they can convey the message that this
skills are critical
it will allow these kids to actually
start taking up assignments in that
domain
because i think data analysis skills if
you one has to learn it has to be the
best learning happens when you do it
partly as structured teaching
but majorly as project based learning
reason is it is it cannot be structured
to a very large extent because as you
rightly said it is an evolving field
and it is evolving so fast that by the
time you bring a structure into practice
it will change
so we need to give them the basic
fundamental understanding of what the
field is rather than start teaching them
very you know only very specific methods
they should be able to adapt to new
methods
and that is where uh training on what is
fair data
what are ontologies
what is basically when you say reference
human genome what is reference and i
think all of this can be taught by life
science faculty in universities you
don't need any kind of data analysis
skills to do that
so i think the way to approach this
problem
is to have to train teachers
to convey this message across to the
students
and then you will actually see the real
impact of the new education policy also
if we do it the more traditional ways we
have been doing will not be able to
scale it up
and that is i think a more logical
practical way of approaching this
problem
yeah that's a great point actually
um which act which kind of simplifies
this for many faculty who might be
something
yes yes i was coming to you
so as she rightly said that you know
it's uh obviously the manpower which is
missing but at the same time at the i
think uh
at the school level when we are having
eleventh and fifth uh what i have
observed is you know the
boards have actually given them choices
of taking either biology or mathematics
so many times you know the students are
not taught mathematics and when we are
talking about data science you cannot do
without mathematics you know that's a
very big
um i think negative that i can see and
for that you know it's very difficult to
tease them
so the people who are actually coming
from with the biology background
they are actually uh because they are
scared of mathematics and without
mathematics it's very difficult to get
people and train them as well
right so i was under the impression that
uh people are allowed to take both
because when i did my 11 12 there was no
minding on not taking maths and biology
together yeah i i agree that even i was
of the same impression but then
that this is my personal uh experience i
would say so one of my very close
relative actually she told me i was like
forcing her that don't do that but then
she said that no the school is straight
away saying that either you go for
biology of mathematics so when the
students used to concerns to take up
first-year students when they used to
say i did never believed it but you know
having a experience of this kind i saw
that that's not the fact
so i think you cannot just segregate
biology with mathematics when we are
talking about data science and something
which is really
uh the need of the r we can say
um i just want to add here that maybe
there is a silver lining which is
statistics so uh statistics i think uh
by utilizing statistics and uh we
we do have those in the curriculum in
most of the
most of the
biotechnology and all those allied
fields
and uh we think that uh maybe data
science is an advanced way advanced
statistics that we are utilizing and uh
maybe if it is only application based
not like coding based uh because when
many of the bioinformatics challenges
are to develop maybe uh some of these
pipelines workflows but uh many of the
biologists are just trying to find uh
ways to analyze it and get to the
biological part of it more deep dive
into the pathways and look at the
mechanism and understand all those
things maybe they can utilize the data
science as a tool rather than data
science going in depth of data science
what do you think
yeah i think what you are referring to
is something which in which in gaming
terms see i'm also a gamer so i always
go back to the gaming concept so uh it
is called as onboarding
so the learning curve cannot be very
steep
so you need to first on board and then
there is a concept of scaffolding where
you really get people involved in the
process so i think before the the
anybody not just school children anybody
coming into data sciences there has to
be an onboarding step which has to be a
small you know learning curve
and then you start going on from there
and that is why i think project based
learning is important because you have a
question in mind
there will be some basic interest
because normally what i see in a lot of
universities because i actually go and
teach at a lot of places
is that the compute the programming is
taught by computer science faculty
there is no context of biology
students fail to make the connection
between why you know where do i use what
so i think that is where you need
interdisciplinary faculty who can bring
that context
and then if that is not possible do a
project-based learning at least the
question is clear in their mind so no
they at least understand what they're
doing i completely agree with
you now i think this makes sense in the
context of the presentation also that dr
anshu's presentation covered very basic
uh understanding of where these
technologies can be applied so maybe a
keyword based like you're saying that
people need to be more like students
need to be become more and more
comfortable with this uh basic part of
the the these like reference genome you
said ontologies you said fair data so
these are very common um terminologies
that could be a part of the basic
training and after the basic training
when they are comfortable um it would be
more about project based training so
that would be a proper pipeline maybe
after the basic understanding you do a
project based
learning and choose your own
specialization choose your own um maybe
application of bioinformatics that in
metagenomics i'll do this in
transcriptomics i'll do this and uh in
structural bioinformatics i can do this
so that clarity if it's there and you
also said that if if that is something
that a life science uh faculty can
easily teach can easily help the student
community understand some of those facts
to get them more interested and more
exploring exploring by themselves and
get that enthusiasm um which is uh right
now missing maybe due to
not being aware and also some fear of
mathematics and algorithms and all of
that see i think what i'll just take ten
more seconds is to also understand that
till the time the research faculty get
convinced that data sciences are
important the message will not trickle
down
and i think the alpha fault
has
been able to make that mental impact
when experimental biologists are able to
appreciate why data sciences are so
critical i think before that there was
partial acceptance with alpha phone that
acceptance has gone multiple foods so i
think this is a right time for us you
know it's like when the iron is hot kind
of the situation so right now is the
time when it can really make them
that message has to trickle down and i
think that message has only come from
data scientist people will not accept it
it has to be the entire community
speaking the same same language
so you're saying we were looking for
more validation maybe a few ai based
drugs and
then we will be more uh accepting
it
yeah which is i think more acceptance uh
for the insidico part of the work rather
than you know just
uh
allowing that wet lab
believing the wet lab results
all right that's i think that concludes
this is a great point and i think we can
now maybe move to the next point which
brings us to the
challenge of how like uh you think that
integration of this hybrid training
which is like many universities they
believe and many institutions and many
students they think that uh maybe uh
going to
uh the university or and working uh is
the right or way of learning but uh
during the covet uh many universities
face this challenge of training students
online and
and then they they were able to do this
successfully but do you see an
integration of both of them because i i
saw that
latest
latest announcement by our prime
minister and he was emphasizing on that
that there should be an hybrid model so
what are your thoughts about this hybrid
model and is it possible because in
bioinformatics and data science yes that
is possible but in an educational system
is it something that is going to happen
so
i make some points that is uh
when in the pandemic situation
so uh we
turn from offline to online
suddenly
and uh it is difficult for first one
semester uh we have found a lot of
difficulties that
and also
in virtual world uh you need your proper
attention uh when the lecture or
anything
if you just sitting in front of
computers or time being and if you not
listening in properly you not understand
and you need to revise uh and you read
it again
so uh that issues are there in the
online system but
we are escaped from that for
computational biology because we
successfully conducted all the
practicals uh all the theory lecture but
also uh that is the students
in your presence when they are learning
then it is uh some a different impact is
there
impact is there if everything is online
it is a little bit difficult to not
understand and uh
we also evaluated the student
after examination
oh the score of means passing percentage
of the student
uh in lockdown period is of university
around 95 to 98
and
uh then after uh
now physically they are attending and in
this semester it is suddenly dropped
till 70
so huge different 30 difference
means many peoples are qualified this
because mcqs are there and open book
exams are conducted by the
colleges and universities
and that's why there are
uh what we can say misuse of this and by
and even though the knowledge level of
the student is not that much means if
you just uh
when as a teacher you just recall the
previous thing because the syllabus is
designed in such a way that you need to
remember the earlier semester thing then
you just um able to go for the next
subject but then
so it is very difficult to teacher uh
to
teach each and every subject in one life
only the thing is that if they are doing
the specific courses
courses on their own
on their own means
the university system is different but
if the students are doing a process in
online
that's why
a little bit problem but finally
the system is online or offline
doesn't matter that is
that student or that
participant would have attention towards
the lecture
and in the national
any time and as per his or her choice
uh he can of the subject and so on
because if you know the first time 12th
past the students they actually don't
know what
subject is this actually what i how to
even though it is imposed by the parent
on that is you have to learn these and
this subject is
subject
but student come to know after 2-3 years
when he is in last year of graduation uh
he come to know the subject is good one
and what he like and according to that
the ability change and that's why this
in our system in nap easily uh
good for the student at the last stage
they can switch and they just go into
the interested
all right
thank you so much i mean that kind of
is
in between and i think kovid 19 has
helped us
maybe through these challenges to us and
now we have this experience of working
online and saw those challenges now
there are good things that we can take
from there and that has been taken up
already and uh there is an integration
and there is more flexibility and
customization that could be more
personalized and that personalized
training is maybe an answer is one of
some of the answers required for maybe
better training and better outcome for
every student because we also get like
good students but there are some
students who are uh who have not been
able to do that in in such focused way
which which they should have so i think
great point and that's uh that's
something that is a great thing for
moving forward that brings us to our
last uh last question yeah
here
so see the hybrid mode that
the prime minister is talking about uh
so there are two ways of doing that
first is we can actually have d y i k s
and this is not something which is
hypothetical we are already making a lot
of dyi components and sending to the
students and they can actually try it
out at their home so they actually learn
to do experiments hands-on
second is we are also generating a lot
of
you know this virtual reality content
where you actually have that haptic
sense of controlling things and doing
the experiment sitting at home
so obviously the hybrid method will
actually involve both but yeah but this
is something where the content is
increasing day by day and dyi kits are
also increasing
i would strongly recommend people not to
do this but if you really need to
generate a
mutant
fly
or to do crispr believe me every single
component of that is available on amazon
so you don't need any lab to generate a
mutant fly as of today you can do that
this is a very heavily unregulated
domain that requires a lot of regulation
but to tell you that if you really want
to do experiments possible so we need to
put that to good use now
yeah that's great to know that diy and
vr is making to the education where this
has a
maybe huge huge
future and impact and also maybe
business opportunities for startups and
students who are graduating now and uh
they would be the ones who can maybe do
this more in this in their field so yeah
great great
one more uh point to this hybrid mode
that all of us have gone through so it's
not only just the students like it is
saying it from from the point of
students even with regards to teachers
also you know it becomes very difficult
to convey your message because it's not
you cannot see the expression of the
students
and uh you know so that also makes it
demoralizes us also some extent because
we don't know whether what we are saying
are they able to grasp it or not and
whether you know we are just talking to
walls
so that again makes it difficult and
with regards to when we are talking
about bioinformatics or any
computational uh
experiments like
work that we are doing we are also
unable to see what they are doing is
correct or not
it might be they have got some result
but is it the right one or are they
going uh by the right way is what which
is very difficult to monitor also
it's both sided and uh once the person
who is delivering also becomes
monotonous then obviously whatever
interest is there that also goes on
so
hybrid does uh you know restrict even us
to get to some kind of innovative
measures to help them enjoy learning
yeah so you're saying that
so i think many institutions made the
video compulsory so that they can see
the students and but it's not possible
when you're looking at a bigger class
it's just does not make even say we have
connection issues you know there's
there's no yeah
and another challenge that you have
mentioned is also to track progress like
how to properly track progress of the
students who are doing these things
online where you don't see them
actually completing or maybe how they're
completing it and if they're learning
all of that or not and then all of this
is kind of like uh maybe at one time you
see the expression and as a teacher you
understand that this is the this is what
he the student has got but that is
missing and which is a demotivating
factor but yeah i mean pros and cons
some of the things that we have learned
is that by using technology this
experience can be improved
far uh better and that's where we are
heading so the use of technology and
then use of
mentors and the requirement of mentors
in this field is something i also like
to point out that is also a requirement
and those students who are now getting
educated and trained would be
could be those resources so there is
this need of capacity student capacity
based
[Music]
that is required for the industry as
well as for the academy
so those with those points
i think we can maybe move to the last
point we are running out of time um but
uh about the promising areas that uh
please uh i think if all of you can just
tell two of the promising areas where
where this
biotechnology and bioinformatics and
computational biology is heading so
precision medicine is one such area that
dr anshu has already recommended and i
would like to ask dr suchi and
dr sagar also to recommend students that
maybe these are the promising areas
where the industry will be requiring
students the academy will be requiring
students for research
so uh
like promising area obviously one is
precision medicine that we're talking
about personalized medicine is something
which is really a promising area that is
there uh by using you know
bioinformatics and the omix technologies
that's because uh by uh studying a
particular uh person's
complete dna i think we can actually
find out
the the things that are specific to that
person
and that would actually help us to be uh
you know giving a personalized medicine
in fact using the uh data that can be
generated say simply like uh we are
talking about uh taking the all the
you know data from blood sample and
urine sample we can actually analyze and
generate models where we can see what is
one thing that is increasing in a
particular group of people and not in
the other group so comparing those kind
of
information that is available now if you
see it practically when
there are loads of people who are
getting their blood test done every day
urine is done every day but that data is
really very important from the research
point of view which is actually going
ways at present so that's one area where
we can actually think of exploring and
that would actually help us to generate
uh quite a few models you know so there
are certain parameters where if it fits
the management okay this model can be
used and that would help the doctors to
uh prescribe medicines and also help
them to uh you know uh
guide them as to the right lifestyle
that they could lead for helping them in
a good
way so they can lead a good life
accordingly so that can be obviously
with regards to various diseases that we
have
all right i think electronic health
records and analysis of that data you're
saying is very important and they could
play a important role
so
from my point of view there are
a lot of opportunity actually
in the market
people are searching for
data scientist
if you see that machine learning is
there
artificial intelligence is there ngs
data analysis is there
so
our r is there those people are able to
handle the python is there
so
those people who have expertise if you
just uh put a single cell
on job.ac dot uk
you will find there are the thousands of
positions are there
uh that peoples are waiting for skilled
manpower
who have expertise in this particular
area
that
people's biologists are there the issue
is that biologists are there or hardcore
biologists they don't know
and computational biologists
computational people are there they are
good in uh
the computation but they don't know
biology so
that is uh peoples are one example i
will
that is uh
in one
hospital they just collecting a data
and
they
um their requirement is
of the person who is able to process the
data medical data and present in the
graphical representation and the
searching for the person
uh who
have experience in our package
and they say that
any amount means package they will offer
so that is the
opportunity which is already present
outside
but uh people need to learn the python
are
machine learning or artificial
intelligence and engineers data analysis
a lot of opportunities are there
and
now the university systems are also
implementing this but uh there is also
limitation for msc by technology how
much subject you incorporate of data
science rather than uh
means you need to focus more on
biotechnology best that some additional
subject you can add but those are
interested they can learn these uh
additional courses from i hope you are
offering the courses in data science and
so on so
uh
student can join and they can learn the
data from specific component from
uh
other
institute as well
so
this is all about the opportunity
which are there
and i i hope that
if the student developed the interest in
the computational biology
it is
very uh
flourishing and now the advanced feeling
but the thing is that
uh you need to update yourself every
time
because the thing which are there in
last year it is tremendously changing
next year so you need to keep you
updated and then you will survive in
this area
thank you thank you thank you dr sarger
for those insights and
important skill sets for students to
take home uh take notes off for data
science machine learning and python
so maybe if dr anshu you can conclude
shortly we are just out of time for the
next student poster presentation
so i think what the what
and sagar has said has very very
critical components
so what uh the actual students got a lot
of keywords
they may add network medicine to it
because it's like you know combining all
of that together so if you have the
right keywords on google
you will be able to fetch the right
information i think searching is also a
very important skill set don't
underestimate that if you don't have the
right keywords you may not be able to
land on the right resources
so i think all the faculty gave you a
very good set of keywords today
go for that and a request to dr sagar if
you can list sites
where
you know there is a consolidated list of
what the current requirements for
industry and academy are i think
students can take a look at that and
take cues from there to start practicing
all right thank you so much all the
panelists for being a part of the somix
research symposium and we are really
really
happy to have you all and learn so much
from these sessions and i hope that the
same goes for all the participants who
have been part of this
discussion and we have also this being
shared live on youtube where we have a
lot of users watching this